the third evaluation Criterion are your
client abilities so how well are you to
work with and interact with your clients
and this can take all kinds of forms for
sure your ability to lead client
meetings to lead interviews with clients
to communicate things well to clients
will play a role here also often your
abilities to create written documents
that are then presented in front of
clients that are shown in front of
clients goes into that as well but here
also your overall ability to build a
trust-based relationship but the extent
to which the client really wants to work
with you because the client sees you as
a trusted advisor